but guys forcing all the social media
Instagram Twitter Facebook fancy Foster
constant kissing trigger pod follow us
all that's on kill it already come on
follow us follow us follow us
well well well hello and welcome to what
will be a very special very very special
show tonight it is going to be uh those
of you who watch Raw it's going to be a
little bit like raw but those of you who
don't watch Raw I mean you're in for a
treat tonight because Francis which is
going to play an hour of francis's worst
clips from raw yes that is all that
we're gonna do so
sorry to say to a Christian or maybe
even a Muslim sit down strapping because
it's gonna get spicy trap in strap on it
is going to be great Francis by the way
Anton has put us uh we're looking in
another Direction obviously on the other
part of the set do you know what reminds
me of do you remember Lock Stock and Two
Smoking Barrels yeah do you remember how
one of the opening scenes as they're
sitting in the Samoan Pub yeah this is
what it looks like it's a purple [__]
lighting with some flowers we look like
we're in a Samoan Pub mate I've
forgotten how good a film log stocking
too strong barrels is do you know it is
nonsense but it is highly entertaining
fast-paced nonsense
by the way we're raw and intoxicated
tonight so join us if you want to and
we're going to have a [__] great time
by the way uh very pleased to say if you
remember those of you who've watched
that interview with Dan Hardy what you
didn't see is his girlfriend Veronica
uh what what you said girlfriend she's
married now they're married now yeah
with any other guess I would have let it
go but he's very hard mate and so is she
they're both very hard and they're both
very married I would just like to make
that clear exactly very very married
yeah so Veronica Hardy uh just for in
the UFC and won yeah so congratulations
to her and to Dan absolutely [__]
smashed it uh anyway we have an
absolutely fantastic show for you
tonight we're gonna we have been working
well not we no it's nothing
no no no because you know what we set up
this company and it's now time for other
people to work and for me to reap the
benefits it's funny when you called it a
company because a lot of people are
going to be like we told you they're
just Griffin it's all about the money
hey
anyway you sound you sounded like some
some more washed out managing directory
of some kind of business there yeah
exactly burnt out and coked up marriages
I don't want to do any work yeah
marriage is on the rocks he's got a
mistress she's pregnant it's all about
to come Crashing Down
anywho yes
the entire week and in fact more than a
week uh everybody Sophie Anton uh web
squirrel a bunch of others have been
working on content for today we've got
some very very special stuff we've got a
compilation of our favorite moments uh
we have got a day in the life of
trigonometry uh we have got a very funny
uh video that guys have been making just
to show off uh some stuff that's been
happening on the show there's apparently
some special we haven't seen any of it
so far uh so we're looking forward to it
uh and in between we're going to tell
you some stories about the the way the
show's you know how it started and all
of that uh since a lot of you always ask
yeah indeed we're going to be going all
through that
I can't wait for the content the content
is going to be absolutely Sensational
I'm not meant to have seen anything but
I saw a few brief Snippets and it is
absolutely top drawer so we've got so
much to look for do you know what we
sound like mate oh gock one what do you
mean because in every episode he always
promised like here's what's coming up in
the next episode and last episode you
saw this like we've been talking about
how great it's going to be for six
minutes really and people have put up
with it to be fair to them they haven't
left they're still here I mean and it I
mean it is a surprise it is a surprise
and if that's not delusional I don't
know what is but welcome and lovely to
have you on board and of course send
through your super chats and your
paypals we'll read them out any
questions that you want to ask us right
the way through about the history of the
show and all of that send them in we've
actually already got a few technically
you can ask any question you want so if
you want to ask about Simone history you
can do you can't do we don't know
anything about it though no apart from
that Dad Spears probably so that's it
and Tattoos so and they're hard and
they're [__] hard and hard all right
uh science and let's find out what super
chats we've got just for now before we
get into the show itself Paula uh thank
you for the five euros I appreciate it
join them out rabbits we have a twenty
dollars oh my God here we go boys so uh
500 people of all genders yeah 500k
congratulations boys do you know the
real difference between pride month and
Saint Patrick's Day on St Patrick's Day
everyone wishes they were Irish
it's a good job it's a very good joke
Anton has come over he's picking up hats
for us now because we are slightly off
well very much off our face yeah
Dynamite rabbit thank you for the twenty
dollars appreciate them and that uh
cherny P were the 10 euro says
um
societies filled with some britons and
some Smiths I feel sorry for your poor
bigots I would rather be killed by
Russian uh whatever pig dogs
then another idea was Sam Smith
fantastic stuff
you know what I remember when Sam Smith
was originally just a little bit of a
blue-eyed soul singer who had the half
who had a couple of hard decent tunes
and now
I I never knew who Sam Smith was until
you
whatever happened there I mean really no
I don't think anyone knows why it really
happened to me no I mean that's just a
guy do you know what he looks like yeah
he looks like a bloke that otherwise if
he wasn't famous I know a musician
whatever he'd be selling pasties
somewhere up north in Egypt sure that's
what he looks like yeah
isn't it
well I don't know
outfits in there yeah but you know just
if you just take the body yeah and put
him in a chip shop up north yeah it does
make sense it fits it does fit it does
fit
but
I mean you know what is it is a
marketing genius because we all talk
about him it's a fair play
uh bloody Sky says five years and 500
000 Subs how many OG fans are left
though oh
quite a lot I imagine I imagine quite a
lot mate probably quite a big chunk of
the 500 000. yeah yeah yeah but thank
you for the two pounds mate we
appreciate it yeah uh Patricia bottomly
with the 1999 says well done on 500k
Lads thank you very much Patricia
uh Island timekeeper Tom can you pull
River Tin and whatever 10.99
regarding yesterday's putative president
Carlson Tucker is too smart to run for
president but smart enough to make us
think he might interesting point I like
to keep it thank you very much
appreciate it uh solving Mark what the
20 does I mean it's all American dollars
tonight says congrats guys keep up the
good work well we are certainly going to
do that my friend Joanna Moore says I'm
an original listener and we'll get into
uh the original listening ship in a
second solving Mike thank you for the
twenty dollars
a lot of little loves thank you very
much
uh can I actually call for the 2G with a
two quid OG fan reporting in congrats
Lads thanks Kalashnikov you with diamond
Francis
I would never normally read out a
message that's not Super Chat yeah four
reasons of my ethnicity yeah and
religion and religion not that I'm
religious but yeah the joke purposes
that worked yeah Alice Coyne who's he he
freaking cheat does anyone else hate the
accents
this is true
uh Whimsy and ink were the five dollars
let's get that one up Anton
yep uh Whimsy and him with a five
dollars uh if you were super Comic Book
Heroes what would your powers be what
would your powers be mate
but I think we all know I'd get the
accounts done in about two hours mate
absolutely [__] smash those bad boys
yep Excel man
what about you mate what would I what
would my superpowers be I mean I know
but eating I mean I was gonna say the
destroyer of pasta yeah exactly I
haven't eaten Pastor in so long it makes
me sad
nah
actually I was the first time I had it
in weeks was when we went to import with
our fantastic interview repairs Morgan
yeah
well thank you Whimsy and Inc I
appreciate it uh thank you so much and
we've got uh
Sean Sean T uh
lots of OG fans still here inexplicably
also L for James Craig well done Island
on the Grand Slam
so I am on the ground slide I didn't
know that well [__] congratulations
to them yeah Emmy bakalana with the 20
says congrats on the half a million
disgraceful reprobates top job here's to
ongoing success not having to move into
any more Studios and continued bigotry
and top guests this OG listener Salute
You Well we salute you as well ebl you
are one of our favorite favorite
favorite top birds and uh evil feminists
who we have yeah exactly
because we're part of the trans Movement
we are as you've heard yeah anyway next
the first video yeah
okay all right we've got more Super
chats keep them coming but we do have
the first video for you let's get our
headphones in
uh because we're gonna need these
because we're professionals exactly here
we go
do it Anton pull the trigger
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
a fascinating person we have for you to
do it today
hi Francis this is Rachel and I just
wanted to wish you a very happy birthday
happy 50th this little shout out is from
squirrel and I hope that you have a very
very happy birthday do something fun to
celebrate
you just did you said he was a gray man
I
I didn't say I said he was brilliant
someone could be brilliant you said a
great man no I didn't I said a brilliant
man Anton what was it
[Music]
thank you
brilliant brilliant brilliant man
all the time I'm wrong all the time I'm
wrong all the time I'm wrong all the
time hey
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis
[Music]
down my throat every morning
that'll go let's guys my God you know
how to work this algorithm
[Music]
I'm Francis Foster oh come on dog you
gotta do better than that I agree with
you thank you sorry man
on Thursday Harvard's faculty of Arts
and Sciences Dean Claudine gay bro why
did you have you have to pronounce it
like that what the Lord didn't go just
Francis try with me what are you gay
no not gay I don't understand why you
have to say it like that
why
because that's the worst fight
I've got to go apart from Francis just
give me somewhere it's just uh five six
seven eight to say hello and welcome to
trigonometry hello and welcome to
trigonometry we haven't started the
interview yeah I appreciated his accent
a lot by the way that was nice
[Music]
we don't do you guys have like uh
different pets and stuff dogs yeah yeah
what about also hamsters yes yes okay
we're normal people over there yeah
let's do it
okay
hello I'm from Trinidad
what
[Music]
Trinidad in Tobago
is that a pub in Dublin yes
I mean Trinidadian in Tobago
like Constantine and Brian it's really
nice for you guys did you deliberately
wait aren't you Brian
person I don't know how you identify but
I'd love to do you up the stink box and
I sat out there and watched
right out there and that's the one thing
no one's talking about huh that's one
thing I was talking about there was
seven of these women in there
I can see why you brought it up he was
at that point mate I realized I could
never trust another woman again correct
somebody needs to keep that and put it
on local police
and put it on web squirrel can you do
something for me can you clip that and
maybe put a little bit of music behind
it take it like real man yeah
oh
okay so yeah we're very happy thank you
uh web squirrel you're fired Anton why
is web squirrel fired because of that
[__] intro what was coming out of my
ass and why was it a brown puddle same
thing as always mate yeah
yeah it is
there we go yeah would you bum a chicken
to save the world
[Music]
you realize the camera is on yeah
and you've just asked me whether I would
bum a
an animal to save the world
anyway to save the world yeah to save
the world otherwise we're all dead cool
competent courageous I mean it's a
massive [__]
hmm
France what Mike
huge
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice that was [__] insanely good
squirrel web squirrel you're absolute
[__] legend that was so good man you
smashed it oh my god did you guys enjoy
that that was [__] incredible
you know what that's made me think we
should put it up on the channel as a bit
of content I agree with you Brian I mean
that is so funny I forgot about that so
did I oh Paul Miller oh
okay
mate that was hilarious it was funny all
right we've got to pay Palio from Nora
what does she say what does Nora say
from Saudi Arabia what does he say he
says since you reached 500k it's time to
upgrade your Arabian accent as well
Nora we're gonna listen to me love right
we're gonna stay true to our Roots
exactly we're going to respect the OG
fans bloody Skies made the point earlier
yeah they we started with the terrible
accents and that is how it's gonna stay
exactly we're not going to work on them
no I mean we could pay an accent coach
why would we do that when they're so
good exactly
what do you mean why listen
hey I can do any accent I've told you
I can do any action yeah yeah
look Nico tested me on the three speech
podcast and I did the Nigerian smashed
it and what did he say yeah he said
that's racist
[__] up
mate you can [__] talk what are you
talking about I've told I did my I did
my my Trinidadian my uh Trinidadian
accent Fame
and he said he sounded more African but
it's not the point
nailed it
what do you mean it's not the point you
just confused two countries populated by
black people yeah right in the normal
World outside of the trigonometry rule
yeah they call that racist no they don't
yeah they do
they why don't you go and clip that and
put it on Twitter mate well see what
happens okay what
wait they they should just thoughts that
are coming out of my head
right Anton I think we should move on
he's a little bit High
ground attack with the five pounds
ground attack one of the OG's as well
appreciate it thank you so much
fantastic stuff
is Jonathan King the famous pedophile
yes although technically given these a
pedophile he's probably Infamous yeah
yeah Infamous the infamous pedophile but
and this is a great thing about trig
mate yeah we have got
fans from all different walks of life
including the map Community including
the Peter Community the map Community
yeah so we're very good so we're very
happy couldn't let this Landmark go by
without a message from your favorite
celebrity viewer you're gonna use this
stream to announce my impending preview
interview interview thanks Jonathan uh
no we're not me we're not in Torpedoes
although we do get the occasional
request
lose Laura smart with a 50 Quid let's
get some Chimneys in the chat for the
wonderful Laura smart from up North up
north now this is an opportunity for us
to make a little announcement yeah which
is Laura smart is now working with us at
trigonometry yep uh and so Francis
people always said we found a very good
way to monetize our audience yeah we've
monetized our employees as well mate
exactly absolutely smashed it that's how
you know congratulations Laura you are
the best employee we've ever had in that
you give us money
exactly thank you Laura
Harvey Hamilton with a hundred dollars
thank you Hobie uh to be yourself in a
world can constantly trying to make you
into someone else is a great
accomplishment to get 500k Subs through
problematic interviews Pagan jokes and
terrible accents is amazing get the belt
hashtag Anton telescope hashtag big
biscuits hashtag Best Is Yet To Come
Colby thank you very much let's get some
more American flags in the chat top
level bigger that is Colby Hamilton we
actually got to meet him we were in
Austin he's a lovely fella and he gave
us several presents one of them which
was a plastic component of a gun yeah
I mean you know so he's unique he is
unique he's special yep Colby thank you
very much I appreciate it hold me the
Colby Paul from the 100 says hello
YouTube
California if you love to call the
foreign
thank you very much appreciate it Paul
Paul that's the most polish surname you
can get mate really
it's just a sound
okay Elaine Bella okay how do you say
that yeah
Scott Adams went on a beautiful rant
today must see oh [__] you know
lovely thank you Dwayne appreciate it uh
Joseph Queen
look we occupied your country for nearly
Century or however long it was
why didn't you learn English exactly why
do you learn Afrikaans what is that what
is his accent we create the British not
me because I was not British then he
created concentration camp to teach you
English exactly and you put this [__] in
super [__] exactly what is going on hang
your head in shame yes Joseph yes
whatever that means
Claudia Von Ayers okay so we have to do
I think with the helmet yes we need the
helmet to do Claudia's accent you think
she's German I think we've been named
like Claudia Vonage
Jeffrey and versus Muslim you speak
against gender identity ideology that is
do you want the dead child on
indoctrinated child
I will leave with a put on my back so my
child is safe after we change this Anton
is it the fact that we're off on that or
does that Super Chat not make a lot of
sense
and and by the way have you got your mic
on
Anton yes and this is a special stream
for you we've got a little bit of
Anton's uh beautiful uh you know
whatever the word is for for the noises
like
terms is you yeah what about Anton it's
so it's like the screeching of a car
isn't it yeah yeah
I would say it's like a poetic School
I'm just happy because Everton have just
um equalized in the last minute against
Chelsea
told you Chelsea was [__] the thing is
Anton really plays down his Scout accent
with us no yeah he does because he knows
he's got to be professional yeah exactly
yeah yeah you wouldn't give you wouldn't
want to give people the wrong impression
exactly you know people otherwise people
are going to be here they're going to be
on edge yeah I mean we do ask guests to
leave their phones and bags over there
by the wall exactly we wouldn't
necessarily have an easy time persuading
them exactly not us we think you're fine
yeah we do yeah I mean we didn't
initially but then five years is a long
time we think you're fine you know the
rest of your people I mean that's a
different story yeah so I mean there's
no smoke without fire exactly
for at least one of you that might be
the only possible hair expression
he looks better with it he looks like
his hero
my [__] massive as well mate yeah
Marco thank you Casey can't uh
Casey Khan
well the fortnite 420 because each of
you each of you favorite meal from your
U.S trip
uh we're all gonna have the same answer
yeah it's the it's the territory blacks
Barbecue in Austin yeah [__] insane
thank you Casey although the meal we had
with Nathan Woodard was very special
yeah that was great and that was an
Italian Gap in New York yeah so then
here we go
says OG OG fan signing in grad's on the
500 000 and thanks for years of great
interviews and entertainment onwards
towards the elusive Diamond play button
thank you very much appreciate it now
Anton how about shall we show people how
the sausage is made I think we should
here is a day in the life of
trigonometry
foreign
[Music]
this is Elliot filming a day in the life
of trigonometry and the crew you've
already met before nice to meet you so
yes as you can see the Green Room isn't
quite finished but we'll show you the
studio hopefully you'll be more
impressed by that I like the green yes
that was actually some one of our team
that painted it well this entire space
from this wall to the very end of the
wall over there was one big empty room
none of this was here none of what you
see but this petition wall was there
this partition wall was not there
the kitchen wasn't there the table
nothing was here all right and then if
you come and have a look at the studio
itself all of this is built you know the
brick wall the side walls that allow us
to have different sides of lighting on
the side all of this the storage room
everything we've done ourselves
basically so it's been it's quite an
improvement on a bed setting yeah
exactly exactly what we'll do is we'll
get some drinks ready
oh and I need to go and do my makeup
actually so we act do you know that we
had a woman from one of the biggest TV
shows in Britain come and train the time
to do our makeup
he's not talking to me just how it
should be makeup with KK
[Music]
first I don't know what this is but it's
some kind of photo finish smooth and
blood this is so my forehead is like
shiny
well just my whole face really so as you
can see right now my face is a mix of
like red patches and black eyes because
Nikolai won't let me sleep and the idea
of makeup is to make very little impact
on that whatsoever because I still look
like that then we do the brown stuff to
go making me look even more Pakistani
than I already do
dab dab dab dab dab as you can see it
creates a nice smooth wait I'm sounding
like some kind of online influencer that
cells make sense
so the idea is to basically smooth it
out so my face looks like it has a
consistent skin tone which it normally
does we've done that
and this is the crucial bit earlier lead
taint velvet I mean this is not natural
is it meant for a man to be doing this
so this is for the black eyes she picked
two different shades that I have to mix
like that and like that and you sort of
blend it in proper Essex orange mate as
my wife said with the first time she saw
me do this makeup you actually look
healthy right so you can see the eyes
are slightly less black can we see that
do we see that no all right and that
ladies and gentlemen so you lose your
masculinity live on camera
you have a great interview with Nigel
bigger some business meetings then raw
then an intern Pierce Morgan it's going
to be a long day did Harman tell you how
he came to us
so he used to work in TV doing basically
what he does for us now tell Nigel's
story after the the George Floyd thing
in 2020 I I was always a bit satisfied
with TV being very prescriptive and what
you could say when you're making
documents you kind of had the conclusion
already and it was what pieces of
evidence do we select to get there that
was your experience yeah pretty much
yeah after the George Floyd moment they
started sending these bizarre emails out
to their staff of color saying um please
tell us what we need to unlearn and yeah
from you so I just I kind of respond as
a joke can you please unlearn my email
address
and they they just
experiences
and teeth and I didn't particularly have
any so they kind of stopped emailing me
but they found a bunch of other people
who had kind of stories that were then
kind of told to the company and it was
just this weird impression put forth of
like the whole company was this kind of
Cloak and Dagger environment with all
this kind of quiet behind the scenes
bigotry and stuff everyone kind of
looked at each other knowing that this
was not how it was but that was just the
sheer force of that was the direction we
were going in so it actually started to
make me feel quite weird I kind of you
know I was very much treated on account
of my race not in like an over erase
this way but also it was kind of not
something people could ignore you know
so I just send these guys an email and
said you know you guys I know you're
racist yeah yeah but that's but it's
kind of straightforward so you knew what
you were getting it's not like yeah
exactly I think for a lot of people it's
just a relief to be an environment and
for me and for us it's actually just
where none of that lasts we just care
about the work you know and we employ
whoever you know we and we talked about
this when we were open we have like
someone who works for us as gender
dysphoria someone who makes images for
us who's trans
so what we're saying is the system isn't
perfect we're trying to striving to be
white and male neither
exactly we're a Dying Breed mate yeah
shall we go and do the interview yeah
cool let's go do it
this is where the KK Jackets live
it's tidy as you can see this gets
tidied once a week and it just returns
yeah well just a Blazer no no you don't
need to sure oh yeah you look great in
the grass it's a very interesting story
I was listening to you on a podcast
Yesterday by whatever research I think
before the book came out you said I
can't think of anything more Comfort
cultural so I just got the impression he
was nervous the Francis I'm far too
important I was going to say it's much
better to be feared for your
controversial nature than to be ignored
so I prefer to think he was terrified
all right we're ready
hello and welcome to trigonometry good
to hear Nigel that's us thank you very
much
there we go fantastic
great you do such a good job you two are
we just uh uh um I mean it's to all the
pleasure to speak to you you ask
interesting questions and just in terms
of your contribution to
public discussion really important well
done thank you thank you
oh the interview is brilliant uh really
really enjoyable great fun it's one of
our favorite things at trigonometry for
both me and Constantine and the viewers
and listeners to get a historian on it
just it's one of our favorite ever
episodes
specifically you could have said you
know Nigel is one of our favorite guests
no two historians mate you know what you
know what I like about my wife is women
are great yeah I mean let's not go too
far
you're gonna give Nigel a copy of my
book in case he gets bored on the toilet
on the train
or something or runs out of toilet paper
or runs out of toilet paper is Elliot
helpfully said he's now fired by the way
no wait no Ellie you're gonna make this
then you're fine
here we go
great we're just throwing ideas around
and we wanted something that would be
sort of like half a trigger warning half
incitement to like this could be
interesting
um
my mom knitted this you know
she's very proud as am I it's very nice
you know what I'll have a lampshit as
well okay
and then whatever you're having okay
thank you may seem like wasteful
spending by the way uh but it's not
because we don't have we do actually
cook quite a bit just we literally have
no time today we got here the guys had
to set up then the interview now we're
gonna have a couple of meetings then
we're doing raw then after all I'm doing
Pierce Morgan to slag off garalinica
which he deserves and then pack down put
out a clip from raw so we won't be out
of here until about 10 o'clock so that's
how our days usually are especially
Thursday Friday Saturday when we're
doing abroad I'm superior probably
wouldn't want to do an interview
particularly on a Saturday because
I always forget
your face
so we've got the breakdown for rules so
this rule we're going to be covering
lineker and broverman swella brogman the
Home Secretary has said she's been
deeply offended by Gary lineker's
comments because everyone's [__]
deeply offended now because her husband
is Jewish uh number four is the New York
Times always a great publication would
you date a podcast bro
and number five we'll be talking about
Rogan's comedy club which opened a
couple of days ago done mate
Parcels are right my name which usually
means Anton oh
Anton has been spending company money
well
Laura smart uh got us an Xbox uh and uh
he's bought us whatever the [__] this is
is it a wireless controller
anyway I actually while she was doing
Piers Morgan I might have a go on the
old Xbox have we got any games
don't think so we never have time to do
anything I don't know why he's bought
this to be honest yeah anyway maybe we
should have got Nigel bigger maybe it's
just so there's another controller we
only got one controller no but there's a
white one yeah yeah so we got two we do
now oh well okay that's what I was
saying he's bought the second one yeah
yeah oh right I wasn't listening to that
bit
so we're just in the final stages of
sorting out our America trip it's really
exciting we've got some incredible
guests lined up we're going to go to a
couple of States we're not going to do
what we did last time which is go to
practically every state in the United
States because that meant that we nearly
died but we've got some amazing guests
lined up we're going to go to some
brilliant cities this is part one and
then we've got part two of America trip
coming up later on in the year so can't
wait for that right now as we're
recording this uh we're uh about a month
out from the trip so we've left it a
little bit late but that's all we always
do it's going to be all fully recorded
um and also uh we're not going to eat
nearly as much as we did last time
Francis has been informed
how do you feel about that Francis
Furious he's Furious
that is good it's is it's a ticket right
so we're waiting for Anton he's run away
as usual normally Francis does a lot of
the cooking and I do sometimes and so
does Anton uh but today we're very short
on time so we ordered the takeaway here
is Anton and there's some food food over
here mate and um yeah we're gonna say
grace Harman doesn't give a [__] he's
already getting stuck in I'd like to say
grace after the meal you know what else
yeah
[Music]
what we're about to receive the many
blessings that are coming our way but
also taking a moment to be grateful for
what we have and everything that we have
achieved in the wonderful people we met
in our journey may we be truly grateful
yeah
of who captured any of the slaves anyone
in the museum right they literally the
Europeans so you've been popular media
like
great use of company money I I pause it
I'm kidding man I'm kidding
[Applause]
see what they're making me [__] do
ORS
so too hot just burn myself
[Music]
all right here we go
let's get ready to Roar
[Music]
thank you
foreign
and after this we're finally going to
wrap up well we've got to pick a clip
from the raw and the title and thumb and
then we'll be ready to go Anton's gonna
get home before midnight tonight which
is uh early they're talking about Harry
and Megan
is that what you were on to talk about
hey is that what you're on to talk about
thankfully not I want to talk about uh
Gary lineker but they're talking about
Harry and Megan do you feel like you're
back on down one
is this not exactly the problem thanks
for having me I appreciate it take care
thank you
[Music]
so there you go that is the day in the
life of trigonometry uh
that was [__] great that was
brilliant that was great that was
brilliant and also what an interview as
well
oh Nigel yeah that's going to be a
[__] incredible interview coming out
absolutely man
Nigel is one of our very favorite guests
absolutely brilliant Nigel bigger the
historian yes indeed Nigel bigger the
historian and it was a great chat all
about colonialism all about the good
stuff wasn't controversial in the
slightest then we moved into slavery
that took about 20 minutes yep so that
was it was just it was just a banter
start to finish but genuinely brilliant
and actually there was a little bit of
banter in there as well there was indeed
Anton let's catch up on the super
chattios find out what the beautiful
bigots are saying this one we've already
done mate yeah we have indeed
she says
ruined my sex life oh she's Portuguese
man
thanks a lot Francis
I'm surprised the new place and this is
a good mate well done
yeah he's actually yeah Portuguese
language is similar to Russian as well
it sounds very similar
Paula well well there you go we know the
pal is a lesbian yeah exactly
you know I mean why else would it ruin
your sex life exactly can't handle it we
have a a message from a very special
person who is one Mrs Anton
ah AKA Anton's mum not his actual Mrs
just to be clear there is no confusion
about that in the Anton household let's
be clear exactly they're Greek they're
not that Greek I can't believe I just
said things I can't believe you just
said that either I cannot believe you
just said that she's a lovely lady she
is and she deserves to be treated with
utmost respect exactly not least because
other sun is also very hard yeah says
you can read this out uh congratulations
Constantine congratulations Francis and
congratulations to mummy's Little
Soldier
yeah huh
she helpfully put in Brackets Anton yeah
well done you all deserve your success
very proud of you all even when you
being sweary crude little buggers which
is every night she said we'll be over to
celebrate with you at some point so get
the champers on ice and tidy the [__] up
lots of love uh well Mrs Anton we cannot
wait to see you and there's always
champagne in the fridge waiting for you
so yeah come on down look forward to
seeing you
um fantastic uh Kai with a 20 euros yes
isn't it weird how we spend 20 bucks on
a two-hour movie but we play almost
nothing on hundreds of hours of YouTube
videos congrats and here's the 20 oh
yeah now this is a man who speaks the
truth for us it is this is what we want
people who have and show a little bit of
[__] appreciation decency and [__]
gratitude all the time we're working out
yeah what are you doing we showed you a
day in the life of trigonometry yeah
right it's an interview some meetings
yeah and then another interview and
we've been a takeaway exactly
exactly now we're not saying
we're just like the people who used to
go to war yeah or go down pit yeah
because we're better paid yeah but we
don't live up north exactly but right
we're just saying we work bloody hard
exactly for you for you for us mostly
but for you as well but for you as well
yeah a little bit a little bit and
where's the love where is it there's a
lot of love where is it show me it
give it to me
okay I think what we're trying to say is
you're making a good point and you've
made it beautifully thank you very much
appreciate it
uh so on high like Eagle who's is really
use
uh thanks for the early years best
moments FF and KK and I presume uh that
is Anton forever now we're gonna play
you some of our favorite Clips in a
little while uh but before we do that
Anton someone in the chat says what was
your first ever interview was it Andrew
Doyle and it actually wasn't no it was a
man called Gideon rackman yeah before we
show it this this is funny because
Gideon uh he's a guy who works at the
financial times yeah and let's just say
he's far more mainstream than we are
yeah and I was at an event recently
where it was me and about 20 other
people and he happened to be one of them
and him and I have good banter yeah but
I don't think he's on board with
trigonometry mate really yeah really
sorry because
I introduced him to someone else who's a
big fan of trigonometry yeah and I said
uh oh this is Gideon he was actually our
first guest on the show yeah anyone oh
so I could have strangled that ugly
little baby in his crib
now he was only half joking yeah I think
uh so this is what it looked like this
is what we looked like and this is the
first episode that we had we're only
going to play a few clips of a few
moments of it have a look at this
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much
wow
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kissing
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
about subjects they know nothing about
at trigonometry we don't pretend to be
experts we ask the experts we're here at
the world famous Angel comedy club and
our amazing expert guest this week is
Gideon Rahman who's the chief Foreign
Affairs commentator for the financial
times a renowned author and winner of
the Orwell prize for political
journalism Gideon Rahman welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much
foreign
tell us a little bit about how you are
where you are what was what's your
background what's been your journey to
to this place
um well in a way quite conventional but
like a lot of things you know there's
sort of a bit of chance a bit of luck
chucked in
um so that little glance
I was born in London but my parents were
South African South African Jews and
their parents had been Lithuania and
Latvian so it's just kind of typical
immigrant story there was a whole bunch
of
uh Lithuanian Latvian Jews who I think
intended to go to America and gone on
the wrong boat
and uh sounds like something and ended
up in South Africa so you know okay so
they were there and then uh
For My Good Fortune because you didn't
particularly want to even as a white
person grow up in apartheid South Africa
it's quite a screwed up place
um
my dad was a academic moved to Britain
before I was born so I was born here
um and then yeah you know I I did the
kind of conventional uh path to
um the BBC I guess no I didn't know not
quite I did
but I but I was also I was fortunate in
the sense that you know I now see with
my kids a lot of scratching my head
slime what should I do should I do this
should I do that and I was I was kind of
um knew I wanted to be a journalist very
early on uh I didn't quite know why was
it a respected profession back then
that's exactly fair question
creepy April that's a good [__]
question well you didn't even lose it
then
I'd love it if your editors watching
this but uh but so yeah so then uh so
that then meant that I wasn't quite kind
of um
focused about sort of getting the
so there you go that's what it that is
what it looked like when we first
started uh Anton we don't need to play
the video but uh I I'm a big favor of
just showing France's front on in the
Diana Fleischmann interview because it's
it's a look mate it's a look it's a look
it's a look that I personally welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constance
of people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
boom there you go mate
psychologist at the University of
Portsmouth yeah Dr Dana Flashman
poor Diana
Diana we apologize she loved him
look on the show so obviously she did
yeah
and interview
so good it was except us being idiots
yeah but she was great Diana was [__]
amazing that was our first interview
that did I think big numbers she did 40K
which for us back then was insane I
remember it got 20K after the first week
and we went to see Andrew though show it
so her feet did you remember this I do
and you went to me look let's not get
ahead of ourselves because we're not
going to get 20K every week
and at the time it was very true but it
was
all right Francis shall we shall we play
a few of our favorite no let's do a few
more Super chats yeah and then we'll
play you a few of our absolute favorite
moments from the show Anton let's get
the rest of the super chats up or let's
get stuck into a few more keep sending
them guys oh baby it's nice and water
with the 369 69.
here 369 US Dollars and 69 U.S in cents
please take it and blow it For Old Times
Sake let's get let's go to Trinidad uh
to buy some chicken oh no no to bum some
chicken to eat some burgers get some
gaming cam
B gay for the big Dougie big game for
big Dougie choke laughing at Mr Winter's
Super Chat and let's all single
umbrella everybody yeah keep it up and
stay hard Nathan thank you very much let
us get some American flags in the chat
let's get some statues of Liberty in the
chat an absolutely Smash in some guns as
well thank you in the chat top gentlemen
appreciate it look forward to seeing you
in NYC very soon Nathan thank you very
much
Seth actually with a Fiverr well don't
well don't be lovers on our four million
subscribers call the Family into trig
and now we're a family of bigots yes
that's what you want thank you for their
lives bigotry is sexually contagious
exactly
it's West country accent yeah that is
true the joke yep that is true
that is true sir thank you very much for
the 4.99 appreciate it uh Nathan we're
with another 669 says YouTube would not
take my Super Chat until I blurbed out
uh all of the um words we got you Nathan
thank you very much we knew what you
meant appreciate it nothing
uh I am Holly 101 that's just made my
day have some of my student loan
congrats bigots there we go we got the
young ones in as well yeah exactly do
you know how [__] hot it is to
monetize students it is Pricks won't pay
for anything yeah no so thank you I'm
Holly we are definitely very grateful
that you borrowed some money from the
government yeah that you've never earned
and probably will never pay back and
send it to us that's what you should all
do and then what because actually what
happens is because of tax they're going
to take most of that money so all the
government has just done is given money
to give them some money to get money
back
I don't mind I'm down all right
as long as money's passing through my
hands I am Holly thank you for the five
pounds appreciate it Jess Powell our top
level bird and moderator with the 20
quid says congrats on 500k Lads what are
your future plans well uh we have
massive plans we've always had massive
plans uh there will be all sorts of
other content coming out on the channel
uh and he will uh expand over time for
now we are currently focused on going to
America as you saw in that clip there
about A Day in the Life once we come
back from that one of the things
one of the reasons we we've got Laura
smart on board is she can help us run
the all the [__] admin that is a
[__] pain in the ass that we spent
our entire last five years basically
doing in order to get the show to this
level so remember we went into comedy we
went into commonly partly to avoid admin
yeah that was a [__] mistake anyway
uh so she'll help us deal with that and
that means we can do more of the
creative stuff that we've always wanted
to do so there's amazing stuff coming
down the pipe don't you worry about that
jazz pal thank you for the 20 quid
okay it's Tony Sophie the bleeder says
FF will expand over time
Tony Hart with the 55 Canadians let's
get some Canadian flags in the chat
let's get some Maple Leaves let's get
some concentration camps in the chat for
Tony Hart he's from Canada oh gee
listener KK you are my favorite trans
Bond girl constantly kissing FF you're
my favorite version of Hitler's hair my
top Hitler thanks for getting me through
the pandemic boys also thanks to the
whole bleeding team
thank you very much Tony Hawk appreciate
it with the 55 Canadians and a redneck
Texas mama with a 20 dial says keep
doing what you all are doing you're all
awesome you all are awesome well redneck
Texas Mama we appreciate it thank you so
much
uh Davison Williams
she will grow up watching Raw and she
loves the intro on the mission my
apologies to our future
huh
Dave Harrison with a tenor okay now time
to let you know you owe me an apology
I'd have gone through life without
knowing who Kate smurfweight was you
mentioned her and I needed to go Google
her work disgraceful congrats on 500k
you know what Dave I think you've got a
point about me I apologize I don't ever
apologize because I like to double down
but on this one we've wronged you mate
we have we're really really happy yeah
it's been embarrassing I mean it's
shocking we apologize thank you Dave
cheers for the channel Paul
thank you
Portugal
nice that was that was bad I don't know
how we get away with this to be honest
Nico told me my Jamaica my Trinidadian
accent was racist
and I don't know if he's joking I don't
think anyone knows if he's joking can
you shh thank you very much for the 420.
I appreciate it uh Dave Harrison with
another five it says Antoine scouse he's
a liver puddling different being he has
a job
and being careful with that antique joke
he says thanks Dave thanks Dave
pizza with a fiber congrats gents and
team one million won't be long you guys
deserve it big time thank you very much
for that uh Peter I appreciate the
Fiverr uh Matthew Lee
[Applause]
Canada
bonjour from Canada felicitation for
your 500k shouldn't you be wearing black
fish when reading Canadian superjets
like the Prime Minister we we should be
but more importantly than that mate we
should be wearing blackface and moving
to California exactly because we want
some of that juicy [__] reparations
money man and we'll just say we've
identified as black for the last 10
years we have give it to me give it to
me Daddy next
uh Sean t199 oh my God KK when are you
doing drag race
thanks Shaun T
appreciate it I think that's in response
to the makeup yeah
from uh uh United Arab Emirates
says oh jifan from Dubai reporting
Arabic accent is thank you very much
baby Doc and thank you uh for the Shema
I think
it is June hope where with a 199 well
done fudge Mark fudge moments Dodge
Farmers on the win
is a select club of young mothers
the fudge mamas I'm telling you that is
you know it's not for everybody
yeah but but the people who do like it
really like it
yes Frostburg was a 500 Swedish chronic
let us get some Viking hats in the chat
let's get some axes in the chat because
he says 500 krona for 500 subscribers
congratulations boys well done thank you
for bringing much needed venting and
laughter you keep me and us as I'm sure
saying much love now I'm off my diet and
I have popcorn so bring on this shots
thank you very much appreciate it Anton
I think it is time we go to either mine
or France's favorite Eclipse should we
start with Francis yeah let's do me all
right are we going to do a little intro
right so we were asked what were our
favorite three moments of trigonometry
two moments oh two no it was free but we
kind of went with them down so what were
our favorite three moments from
trigonometry if these are two of mine
and it was look the reality is it's
almost impossible to to do this task
because there have been so many
wonderful moments throughout the show
but these two were very personal to me
uh one was with the comedian Steve
Hughes and if you haven't seen that
interview
it's one of our best but by like a long
way it's incredible [__] brilliant
it's incredible and the thing was when
we originally did it we wanted and this
was a real moment of growth for me on
the show we wanted Steve to come in and
talk about one particular thing comedy
right now Steve didn't want to talk
about comedy yeah and Steve does
whatever the [__] Steve wants so Steve
came in and gave us something completely
different and I and what he was saying
blew our mind so much that when we
actually finished we were like are we
going to be able to put that out yeah
yeah we we thought it wasn't usable
content and it was Anton he went trust
me it's going to be brilliant we're
going to chop a few bits out and it's
going to be incredible and you were
right man and it's one of my favorite
ever interviews and the other interview
is
when I was asked
you asked me uh one of the first things
we did with trigonometry who's the five
guests you dream of having on the show
he was number four or number five for me
David not Dr David nut I absolutely
brilliant former advisor to the Gordon
Brown government and he was a drugs
advisor and he was fired for pointing
out the statistical fact that taking
ecstasy is less dangerous than horse
riding and he was fired for that by the
Brown Governor and also suggesting
decriminalization of marijuana yeah and
he was fired for that
and
as a result he lost his career in
government and he's a brilliant man and
this was a wonderful interview let's
start with that one Anton and then we'll
go to Steve Hughes second
I was a fan of Bill Hicks the comedian
when I started in comedy I was a fan of
Bill Hicks the comedian and when he used
to have this routine about have you ever
noticed it's the drugs that do the least
for you that are legal the ones that get
you to question to push back to think
for yourselves are made illegal
do you agree with that totally it's
genius he was a genius absolutely
completely on track the drugs that make
you question is the establishment
question on governments drugs like
psychedelics they were banned LSD was
banned because people were questioning
the war in Vietnam and because at that
time as is still the case today the only
response of Western governments to drugs
is to ban them they got banned it didn't
affect people using them but it
absolutely hammered people like me you
want to research them and who want to
use them as therapies trans or what who
are you I'm 53 year old man and only
some 20 year old with pink hair to tell
me that I'm a racist I'm like what are
you talking about
[Music]
you don't know anything about me you're
just when I see people there would be
when I grew up around punks and metal
heads
here's why I can understand these young
people when I used to see girls when I
grew up with green hair and Doc Martens
they were cool girls now I see anyone
like that I'm like get them the [__]
away from me
as I said that guy who when he walks up
to some girl in the university and says
you know so what if I identify as a 65
year old Chinese woman
not hurting anybody I don't see what the
problem is and well there's a big
problem he's not a 65 year old child
oh mate that was great that those are
two very very good moments yeah we'll do
mine in a minute Anton let's catch up on
a few more Super chats find out what the
bigots are saying keep them coming
like Eagle is Israeli isn't it yes this
is really he says
many lazy Birds this is true thank you
sir and hi like Eagle appreciate the
249. uh
[Music]
yay
we get the big one out you don't need to
apply makeup just wear francis's glasses
that's right everybody looks bloody
thank you for the five euros appreciate
it
uh Don Jones with a turn ten dollars
says congrats on 500k I was hoping
you're behind the scenes would
accidentally reveal antonovich the most
handsome man we have see we haven't seen
one day you'll slip up one day we may
Don Jones thank you very much until then
Andrew with a two pound uh great result
for Dan Hardy's wife and UFC 286 he's
called Veronica mate yeah she's pretty
[__] hard yeah she's [__] hard and
as a result of that you give her respect
exactly
foreign
about the radioactive testes yesterday
you guys are great Jay thank you very
much thanks very much mate appreciate it
listen what is he saying he's seeing
with a 50 famous
people who are intolent of other
cultures and the Dutch especially the
farmers mate I like the Dutch yeah
I've got no problem with the Dutch
that's fine I mean they're a bit direct
yeah but it's fine yeah yeah
I remember look all of my horny teenage
years I flew KLM by Skip hole I'm just
saying for for for a young man of that
age
it's not a bad experience I can imagine
you know what I mean yes did you talk to
any of them wait I was 15.
I wasn't gonna be [__] chatting up
air hostesses at 15 minutes Anton was
having threesomes
laughs
well you know what I think it is good
that you shared that but perhaps the
night that his mum is watching may not
have been the best one for that hahaha
the Ink's same with five thanks for the
makeup tutorial KK also hi Brian
congrats again well deserved guys
Eastern thank you very much for that
yeah he's incredible Tracy holiday women
ten dollars oh yo authentic Ginger
Yankee right here hello from Florida
where we know what a woman is Tracy
thank you very much for the ten dollars
appreciate it we've also got a bunch of
paypals but keep them coming Anton okay
this
Chris 1980s many congrats on the 500k
kept me Sandra in Kobe pandemic with all
the mainstream media hysteria incredible
interviews from the greatest Minds
onwards to the next one mill you are a
gentleman thank you Chris Chris thank
you very much for that and Nora with the
15 pounds says you always say that Anton
is handsome guy why can't I remember his
face I only remember a body carrying a
camera Pfizer had blocked some of my
finest memories
well our commiserations Nora
uh there we go uh and we have a 124
pounds from someone who says don't use
my real name I mean okay Jeremy I'm
gonna be honest with you mate that I
wouldn't have been able to say it
properly anyway even if I said that name
it's a Dutch Dutch name please let's get
some Dutch Flags no he's Belgian mate
he's a Belgium from the land of the
pedos easy yeah all right he says uh uh
what do Belgian people sound like
they're just French apart from the
Flemish who were just weird and got
this inflam is like half the country
though yeah it is and they get really
angry when you talk to them in French oh
don't use my real name or love your show
people was of will overdue so cheers
from Peter country Belgium where Jimmy
Savile and Gary Glitter heads are
training Belgian bigot on locals Belgium
bigger on locals thank you so much for
that let's get some uh Belgian Flags in
the chat let's get some chocolate let's
get some 80s entertainers in the chat
for the wonderful Belgian bigot thank
you so much for that 124 pounds and I've
advice
get it out get it out mine come on mate
birds love it if it flops pegging and
Joanna with a pound says congrats minky
and Molly thank you very much Joanna
Sonny with the Tanner says congrats on
the 500k Subs love Sunny sunshine and
and I'll fight you naked says well
you've been near DC for the cherry
blossoms it's one of that City saving
Graces we might well be mate yeah well
actually we might well be there it might
well be Anton we'll do a couple more
Super chats before we go to my favorite
moments have a look at this
my guess with a hundred you oh yes
congrats gents let's keep this
trigonometry trying to roll him well
let's get some American flags in the
chat for the wonderful markets and some
freedom and some absolutely [__]
incredible statues of Liberty thank you
very much next
uh need urgent fat shaming with the two
euros
welcome to the painted raw side Museum
the main set at the moment because it's
a combination of raw and non-roll we
thought we'd freshen it up for you
freshen it up for the late and have some
fat shaming as well need urgent fat
shaming I appreciate it remember that
bloke he's used to work in the toilets
in a nightclub
do you remember that
and they would just say freshen up for
the ladies but they wouldn't be able to
talk normally they'd have to it would
always have to be in rhyme
really yeah they'd always I mean I don't
want to spend a lot of time yeah they
always rhymed it and then they gave you
a lollipop
yeah the Rhymes what was it uh
yeah I mean there were some that were
literally
yes that was it no um
you'd probably get canceled for that now
yes although that would be a great
Armani advert yeah it would be normal
just a guy in the toilet going no money
no punani that's Brave that is bold you
know what I mean and the thing was that
is the only way communicated to you in
rhyme Francis you know what we should do
well if we ever get to like Mr Beast
levels yeah which we want but if we do
yeah we should release a a labeled uh uh
labeled or the colon yeah with Armani
yeah and the slogan will be no no no
Frederick horn axelen it was a 59
Norwegian chronic says congratulations
on 500 Subs fully deserved love from
Norway Frederick thank you very much
gentlemen absolutely appreciate that uh
yeah
[Music]
so what are you saying have you heard
about that the new two chat new YouTube
channel and fashioned unfathomable
crimes in the next episode they're
investigating how I translate with weak
arms and teacher joined with cancer for
500 Subs hey mystery for the ages well
said cello sangrietas and of course
everyone should go and follow and
fathomable crimes crimes rather
inspector Clues you always if I pounces
some great behind the scenes stuff there
guys thank you merci beaucoup no worries
appreciate it thank you spectacular uh
tarot with a Fiverr and agree how do you
do a Greek accent I don't know I am
going to do accents like this it's kind
of Turkish time yeah okay but you know
I'm not gonna do the joke yeah same
thing yeah a great on the 500k lunch
been following you since the Weinstein
uh cool for origin videos a video from
interviews to Raw you keep smashing it
yes thank you very much appreciate it uh
tarot thank you for the Fiverr
good food good friends good god let's
eat well said my friend thank you for
that appreciate it uh the Navigator with
the ten dollars says well done I'm
keeping it fun for 500 000 subscribers
while delivering the serious points that
may keep Society on the rails well the
Navigator thank you very much perfect
Jay Curtis with a five
us how about the best of meant to win Mr
winner hour long special yeah the
internet would not survive that speaking
of things the internet will not survive
Anton how about we talk about my
favorite moments so these are two
different moments the first of them is
how we ever got to interview big Dougie
in the first place we were a very small
YouTube channel at the time how many
Subs did we have I don't remember
exactly it was May of 2019.
so we had about 40 000 something like
that yeah uh and we won a big YouTube
channel at the time but I'd already had
my uh no uh no jokes contract situation
and whatever and we got invited to a
small conference in Oxford uh where
Dougie was one of the guests uh Douglas
Murray who were massive fans of and we
re he was like our Dream guest
and
this conference it was like quite a
small one so we were all you know we had
dinner and we were sitting at lunch next
to each other and we had a better bands
and whatever and then uh there was a
drinks reception later and it was almost
like a scene from a movie because I saw
Douglas go out to take a phone call
so I went to the toilet passed him
and basically waited until his phone
call was finished and came out right as
it was finished and I was like oh hey
Douglas so nice chatting with you
earlier by the way I do a YouTube show
would you like to come on yes
yeah that was smooth mate there was I
was with operating but that's what we
had to do yeah imagine if we'd been on
the phone call for an hour well I would
have pretended to have taken a really
long shift I'd walk out go give that a
minute if I you anyway I have a YouTube
channel
huh
so that's the first one it's our first
into Douglas Murray and at the end of it
because we actually did it in Nigel big
ass yeah uh house in Oxford a a woman
walked in who was doing uh some kind of
seminar there at the end yeah and was
very upset that we were in there so we
had to pack up rapidly and wrap up the
interview yeah uh and my second favorite
moment is a beautiful clip from our
YouTube Rod little I'm not even going to
tell you what it's about have a look at
this
charity
to set up legislation Charities begin to
work for legislation legislations is
enacted to protect those people but it
becomes an industry and what always
happens is that it expands so that for
example with disability
at one point there is absolutely no
question of disabled people in this
country had a really really bad run of
it probably still do in many cases they
do actually yeah because my mom says but
but [__] your mum
I guess finally says what I've been
meaning to say for a very long time
but what happens is
that's it do we have a clip
yeah let's just give people the visual
image of our interview with Douglas yeah
hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you're bored of people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts our brilliant guest this
week is a writer journalist and social
commentator Douglas Murray welcome to
trigonometry good to be with you both
questions
there you go yeah that was a wonderful
wonderful interview
it was absolutely loved it Anton let's
catch up on the rest of the super chats
and we have one other special bit of
content we don't know what it is it's a
bunch of special messages as Anton has
told us yeah we don't know what it is
and we're gonna play it in about 10
minutes so keep sending the super chats
keep sending the paypals we'll read them
out and we'll talk about all the good
stuff before we play you that final
video 4-1-1 sketches uh with a super
sticker thank you sir
five pounds for 500 Subs when I get rich
you'll get five plus a few more zeros I
must have fun thank you very much thank
you appreciate it
uh Stacy Howard of the tenor congrats
guys I wish I could contribute regularly
however I'd still I'd still happily
drinking coffee from my public
problematic bleeder mug I love you guys
you make my evenings when I'm not when
I'm not on a late show Stacey thank you
very much oh by the way uh I wonder
Stacy works on late shifts and look at
that photo
Stacy
Francis would like to meet you exactly
thank you very much for the 9.99
yeah
Jackman Ashley with a Fiverr in that
first episode you guys look like the
commentary team for original Chess
Championship
oh man thank you very much Jack
appreciate it Mick with a five pounds
thank you very much appreciate it Don
Mongoose with the 25 says paying my
twice annual big attacks congrats on the
500k and loving the clips so don thank
you very much for the 25. uh Sarah
Sampson with a 50 US dollars
Thanks for the Memories got my friend
KK's book also Adam Coleman and Marion
two piece book seen on trig he raved
about all of them he also light your
Oxford speech Sarah thank you very much
let's get some American flags in the
chat for Sarah Sampson let's get some of
the Californian what would it be
reparations let's get some preparations
in the chat for the wonderful Sarah
Sampson thank you for the fifty dollars
Jimmy Savile
he's [__] dead mate
he's dead Thank God
now when now when I thought I was a king
of the piece but watching KK put more
makeup made even my shrivel
thanks Jimmy
I went now and
Millie Smith with the 10 Canadians okay
Jordan Peterson
um nice to catch you alive for a great
raw love the flashbacks thanks Millie I
appreciate it as well uh uh Steve with
the five dialysis Constantine how was
the response to you Oxford Union talk it
was a [__] incredible man absolutely
incredible thank you very much Steve why
is coyote were the two dialysis congrats
on 500k time for that camera kiss on
camera kiss no we said five million yeah
exactly like would you kiss me full on
the lips for five million pounds yes
yes
pounds five million pounds
would we split it though yeah
with Anton no no I see we play
everything with Anton but not this mate
if we have to do the gay thing yeah
right and he's not involved yeah despite
his ethnic background yeah
I'm not splitting anything with him yeah
I'm not bombing Francis and then giving
you half that money mate
you know what I mean
I didn't go to bombing from becoming a
kid well it's the natural progression
isn't it yeah if if you kissed me you'd
enjoy it so much you'd want a bit of the
bumming mate no I'm a natural mate no
but you are part Greeks those make sense
exactly I told you like real men
JDP Lance is there anyone uh worth
mentioning that is doing something
mildly similar in the UK as you guys no
no obviously not mate yeah right what
are you trying to do here mate well you
sent us a shitty little five euros and
you want to just for us to [__] plug
the competition yeah there is no
competition for this mate no one is this
[__] exactly nobody is doing what
we're doing why would we tell you to go
to Navara media it wouldn't make sense
thank you Tony P appreciate the five
euros
Greg cooling with a five
um
yeah so anyway so on local
do we get some outtakes of evil lovia
pegging airfare while poom poom watches
on just checking on the value congrats
on the Milestone yeah I mean I'm a big
fan of evil lover but even I wouldn't
want to see that Brett Cohen thank you
very much for the five dollars Lindy
Wright says congrats chaps cheers for
manscaping the [__] out of your
brilliant content top shaggers although
KK is the only one who's proved there
correct Lindy absolute top shagger did
it once straight in job done but never
again
reason with a 50
I plan to visit the fudge mamas in the
red light district thank you Joseph yes
and appreciate it uh
Tracy with the five dollar says by the
way great man spread there FF well done
I imagine it's one of the interviews
that we we talked about thank you Tracy
thanks appreciate it uh Jonathan lay
with the 779. congrats from Kentucky say
hi to my wife Leslie please she's a new
fan version and bigger hi Leslie I hope
you're doing good Leslie welcome welcome
very much uh Jonathan thank you Johan
with the circus
he says he that was brilliant
you guys look I only discovered you
recently and the word certainly seems
normal again that is how you know you
have a brain tumor dinner
Johan Johan
David mustard
that's a good name David David the age
[__] mustard mate would you guys
think we should be talking about but
we're not could it be Paul Harrington I
mean look at the two of us
yeah mate David thank you very much for
the five I appreciate it uh Martin with
a Fiverr thank you for that beautiful
Nathan whatever the 669 says don't use
my real name sorry Nathan apologies
uh Jude pants with a tenor congrats
called boys keep it up and stay hard
thank you thank you for the 9.99 uh more
to magic with the 199 says don't use
Nathan woodard's real name thank you
fantastic
uh massive dingo mate that was it that
was another one don't forget no splash
no gas no splash no gas
that was another one I forgot all of
them because I was absolutely off my
tips no Armani no punani that's class
this is [__]
my basement level [__] mate and the
thing was there were millions of no
splash no gas what the [__] massive
dingo with the two quid thank you very
much yeah no spray no Lane yeah that's
another one Christina with the tennis
says I received more than I gave and for
this I will always be grateful to you
and the trigger Community I feel
awkwardly nostalgic but it's a time for
celebration so congratulations well we
don't have cancer Christina yeah exactly
we're going to be around yeah it's fine
thank you
uh using using with a 35 South African
rand Dougie and doily would be nothing
without you well actually uh I have
actually told Andrew to his face many
times that he would be nothing without
me
yeah he agrees he knows he knows the
truth Joseph Eason thank you for this
evening
my craft another Todd bird and another
trigonometry moderator here's to the
next 500k well earned and so much more
to come and a little heart as well top
bird you are Mycroft let's get some
British flags in the chat let's get some
birds in the chat for the wonderful
Minecraft uh who's a beautiful supporter
of the show thank you so much yeah
thanks my Croft uh Cami Anderson with a
two quid KK will kill for ff's old hair
I don't know I'd rather have lesser
thank you Cami I appreciate it uh
schwango with a five dollars firm work
you're doing good doing boys I still get
to hear Francis do the filthiest Cockney
accent I've ever heard oh what what
thank you swanger appreciate it
um uh Demar with the 499 says from some
Helens Johnny Vegas accent
uh so
monkey taught like that
from Saint Helens Johnny Vegas accent
who was your first guess Paul Embry was
the first episode I watched and he made
me aware of you guys well go and watch
the earlier part of the stream we talked
about Gideon rackman who was our first
ever guest demo thank you very much for
the 4.99 uh hands man whether 10
dialysis Californian accent oh my God
congrats on 500k the show keeping up
keep up the great work love the show
love the show hands man thank you very
much for this we're gonna catch up on
the final super chat or a few more Super
chats and then we will play those
special messages Andrew with the two
quizzes going back on Rogan on next trip
uh not the next one because we won't be
in Austin this time but maybe we can we
can uh speak with Joe again uh towards
the end of the year yeah we'll see
appreciate it Avid picks for the 4.99
been watching you since the pegging chat
days top guys well one of you probably
is thanks Avid picks appreciate it
love you boys those days of the uh days
of Boyhood thank you
Anonymous with the Five Dancers going
back uh to the range when you're next in
the US I [__] hope so yeah so start
with a 22 22 caliber until you get
comfortable also step of the Grand
Canyon will be worth it thank you very
much yeah going [__] Desert Eagle
mate
caliber Anonymous thank you
uh forum and Kiko man wash your finger
you dirty minger
mate thank you Jocko spillaneck with the
499 So speaking of man spread odds of a
child with Marilyn Manson regarding
falsely accused voice on his bro Johnny
Depp uh quite low I think yeah yeah
thank you I appreciate it uh Michael
Saunders or Saunders I should say thank
you Michael Flying Scotsman appreciate
it
Peter Riley with a Fiverr thank you from
the northern pension tree thank you
Peter Peter appreciate it and the last
one is Johan uh thank you very much
again and guys here we go we're going to
play you the special messages uh and
then we'll talk about them afterwards we
don't even know what these are let's
have a look yeah
half a million viewers
fish it's YouTube who cares they're a
bunch of fascists anyway seriously well
congratulations to the best podcast
outside of the greatest nation on God's
green earth well done KK well done FF
strongly deserved you guys you keep us
all sane and you do it with a um
sort of humor that we love onward to a
million oh and by the way we're waiting
here we're ready for you let's go back
to the range let's have some fun see you
soon God bless Dr G yeah very well done
500 000 subscribers it's a lot harder
congratulations Francis and Constantine
online 500k subscribers thank you for
being a place of Sanity in a very mad
world but beyond that just being so down
to earth through all of the success
you've had how you've brought so many
guests that have inspired me and led me
in all directions in my thinking and
challenged me
um and that's one thing I think uh many
of us are missing today is being
challenged so please guys keep doing
what you're doing we love it I hope to
see you soon lads
half a million Winnie it's not nothing
not the most prettiest thing ever
hey
boys
hey boys I just wanted to say
congratulations on 500k you guys are
doing amazing work you're doing the
Lord's work just kidding we're not
religious here but you are doing amazing
work and I'm very proud of you and I'm
so proud to have known you since the
very beginning and hopefully I will see
you guys soon in London or let me know
when you're coming to New York or Miami
from everybody at trichonoma trees
yeah
big big big big big congratulations to
making your 500 000 zip coaches
thoroughly deserved and to many more
congratulations Constantine and Francis
for hitting 500 000 subscribers you guys
totally that's okay keep up the good
work and I look forward to watching more
of your inspiring episodes
boom
yay
there he is look at him
it's Nikolai if you don't know him
myself
that
hey
oh man
that's what he does now just grabs onto
things and then Falls over
laughs
ladies and gentlemen I think we can
safely say this has been absolutely
[__] incredible we will put some of
that content out as individual Clips uh
but if you are enjoying the show if you
have been for the last five years uh
thank you so much for that if you want
to support us if you want to continue to
fuel our success because it is all down
to you guys there are two things you can
do make sure you subscribed to the
channel share it with everybody and of
course please join locals give us the
financial support that it gives us the
stability to you saw some of the
elements of our team there we have to
pay them uh we like
unfortunately right and so yeah it's
frustrating mate it's against my
religion as you well know yeah I mean
we've got laws in this country against
making people work for free in that oh
no it's gone down in ever since we've
got really seriously though anytime we
get more money from you guys all we do
is hire another person who can help us
grow the show I think you've seen the
immense growth over the last uh well
five years but in the last year in the
last two years we've just taken off and
that's thanks to you keep supporting us
and we're going to keep producing
amazing content for you and like we
talked about earlier we have huge
ambitious plans so get in early get
yourself a bit of the trigonometry
absolutely
thank you for whenever you've joined
thank you for watching thank you for
liking thank you for talking about it
with other people for bringing other
people to it thank you for sticking with
it when a great guest disagrees with you
and you're not one of those people
I want free speech found if you don't
you agree with me
thank you for everybody thank you for
tuning in thank you for watching the
show
and onward to the next million
if you like British politics with a bit
of comedies and quality great
conversations of honesty get to hear the
thoughts of Asylum majority the sand you
always woke [__] watch trigonometry six
packs of Stella smoke a pack of salmon
Francis Foster has the true essence of a
gamut it's time to call the big boys get
on Steve Bannon cause you gotta push
back the claws off the red dragon I feel
that Brendan on there with the real deal
he's like Morpheus in The Matrix giving
out these red pills but just take one
not the whole bottle that's what Michael
malice said and the man's a role model
just what's your last interview with
David Stark he's a gateway drug got me
feeling like a Nazi that's what these
labor activists celebrity think putting
too much soy milk in the teas that they
drink as for launch Fox they try to put
him in a box to say his views are
problematic and really should just be
docs this madness has to stop the whole
cancer culture is a mess the progressive
left to swarm and Lasting vultures half
Venezuelan other half hooligan you voted
to remain in a European Union because
you're good people having
I see you're on the path to hopefully
make some money how about once a month
bring it back Douglas Murray looking
like a thirst trap and I ain't even gay
dude what comedy is that Cosby with a
quaalude sending me to sleep while I'm
sitting in my seat surrounded by a sea
of virtue signaling sheep he's Owen
Jones types and his social justice mods
and they won't be satisfied until they
take away your jobs looking down on the
white working class like snobs while
they're praying that the pulpit of
progressive Gods to [__] you think tanks
in your left leaning crangles you reach
Peak rank so I'm off for a Nando's
Constantine kissing my favorite Jewish
Nazi are alt-right Russian proper
another patriarchy so like And subscribe
to the YouTube channel if you're sick to
the back teeth for question times panel
I'm out
[Music]
buy a Russian book by comrade
Constantine it will cause political
polarization and bring down Western
democracy